how's it going guys in this video we're
going to talk about how to clean up your
git repos and remove
all past iterations
and i'm going to do it on one of mine as
an example
so hopefully this helps you out and uh
let's get right into it i'm kind of
doing this in a live cast way so
it might be a little messy but we're
gonna walk through all the main steps
and uh let's get right to it so
on my other screen here going to github
and going to a repo that i want to clean
up
okay so i have this repo called dm power
and it's one i just want to uh
clean up and make smaller because right
now like if you clone it you're gonna
get all the history with it too right
and all the branches and all that if you
want to get rid of all the history you
just want to have the latest only and
make it as small as possible for people
clone and work with is what you can do
now keep in mind this is very important
you're going to lose all your old commit
history if you do this you're going to
lose all your old stuff if you do this
and you'll only be left with the latest
version
so
do this at your own discretion back up
what you need to back up all that
and uh let's go
all right so if you clone it right now
that's what you get but we're not going
to clone it right now because we want to
do a few things okay so when we're we're
going to run some things that are going
to remove
a lot of files a lot of old files
and it's all git commands but first
before you do that what you need to do
is get rid of your other branches
that because they'll also have a history
of stuff and if you don't get rid of
them this won't work
and
you also need to get rid of all your
tags
so that's that's kind of it kind of
stinks you know you get rid of all your
tags right
but it's still pretty vitally important
if you want to do this if you've got to
keep your tags then
then don't do this
you know
i've said it you know how to do it if
you want to delete these you gotta
you gotta click on them and go to delete
right here
i'm having a little second thoughts on
whether i should
do it on this repo or not so i'm gonna
do it on a
different repo here yeah let me do it on
dm power 2.
i'll run it on this one because this one
doesn't have much history anyways i've
already deleted all the branches
all that i'm going to yeah i'm going to
run on this one because i don't want to
risk i need to go through that other
repo first before i do all this
basically so i'm going to go ahead and
clone this right i'm going to hit this
button
i'm going to open up
oh you can use what you want i'm going
to use a terminal actually i'll use
use fork here
hit clone
this is the same as doing git clone and
typing in this the normal way you would
we'll use the console some more here in
a second but
we'll go ahead and do this
oh i already have it cloned
so in that case i'm just going to go
ahead and open it
and here we go i've only got a few
things it'll still kind of work here
but yeah just keep in mind
you gotta get rid of all your tags and
other branches
i don't have any on this one so there's
nothing to delete
but if you're using something like fork
you can do a lot of that work here too
but if not you might have to go to
github and do it
i know you're all probably waiting for
these commands but i just want to make
sure i don't miss anything
all right so what you want to do is just
open
the console of course
you're probably here anyway but you
can't do this next part and fork at all
so what you want to do is you want to
check out
an orphan new branch so we're going to
go
get check out dash dash
orphan and we just give it any name i'm
just going to call it
last
yeah we'll call it last that's fine and
it switches to a new branch last and
this is a branch without any
history that's what the orphan is
basically
and now we we're going to do a git
add all
uh
git
add
except rather than do an all we're going
to go or you normally go dot everything
right we want to do this in a special
way with dash a
and what dash a does i'll just bring it
over here actually
is it does
all
with no ignore removal it's basically
the snow ignore removal make sure it
gets all the directories it needs and
dash all just
adds everything if we add all the
current files it's going to be all the
files in the current directory and there
we go was successful i'm going to do an
ls here just so you can see it basically
added all this stuff
okay so that is all well and good
the next step here
we want to
make a commit and push it so uh next
thing we want to do
is get commit
and we're going to do dash am for all
message kind of a shortcut and give it
anything you want i'm just going to call
a fresh call fresh in it but you can
call it initial commit net whatever you
want it's going to be
the message that's on all these files
it that's going to say created a bunch
of stuff let me see if it created stuff
from the out
uh no it didn't okay good i must have my
get ignored correct that's good
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to delete our main branch or
master branch whichever you're calling
it
it is the only branch so we're going to
go get
branch
capital b which is going to delete it
everywhere locally and up on your repo
and main
and
mains gone
so now all we are got is this orphan and
what we're gonna do here
is we're going to rename our orphan to
main so we're going to go get branch
dash m
name
and there we go
it is now
lame named main instead of last
so what we want to do now is just push
this to our origin so we're going to go
get
push
dash f
origin
uh main almost type master
and now we have push this fresh orphan
with no history
up as our mate
and uh
what we're going to do next here is
we're going to
basically do a get garbage collection
that's gc so you got to go get gc
and
we want to do it to the most extreme so
we're going to go
dash aggressive
and we want to make sure we get rid of
everything that doesn't have references
so we're going to go prune equals all
and once this is done running there
wasn't much here because this was a
small repo
it will get rid of all the history so
now if we go back over here
and hit refresh
we'll see we got a
freshen it on all of these and there's
no longer any history
so basically that's what you do
let me know if you have any questions
down below
thanks for watching
matt out peace
[Music]
you